[Music]
you too I'm glad
you're fat Adam get together without
hostilities I should have left years ago
and at 50 I got get to start all over
give every alive right now
fabulous
[Music]
I want you to read it first that would
be a special favor for me
even now from the grave he's well
nothing me Dad I finally had an insight
that sticks to the page must beginning
to worry that I'm really a big fraud
we're all frauds until we come up with a
good idea then we're geniuses
[Music]
do the dates I'm just having an early
dinner with your uncle Paul Adam he's my
brother when he told me he was splitting
up well the plot thickens
hell we should get together from time to
time look coming home you did not write
that play why did you say you could
never worry about love back deeply
because you've never felt left at deeply
[Music]
I'm less happy in a long time serious
mmm let him come to us I think we
shouldn't invite Adam to join us
I don't just add known
[Music]
you
you